[Musik]
wir bringen
hallo herr james elliott wellen gibt
endlich mal wieder was mit süßem
hefeteig ihr wisst liebe ich sehr und
bereit ich auch sehr gerne zu und heute
habe ich vanillepudding schnecken mit
johannisbeeren und die sehen wirklich
super hübsch aus und schmecken lecker
vor allem mit dem vanillepudding und den
habe ich noch verfeinert mit der das
quark so dass das ganze wirklich wieso
diese petition war das bisher aus der
bäckerei kein standard sagt erfreut wie
man ernährungsberater riesig auf seine
ganz toll gemacht hat amerikanischen
hefeteig auch mit dinkel mails zu
bereiten
man kann das ganze auch mit weniger
zucker zu fressen aber mache ich finde
wir machen ja es ist also wirklich nicht
oft ihr denkt ist zwar immer aber es
gibt wirklich nicht so oft süße sachen
besinnt und bist du geselligen karmann
ok und die sonne nicht um seine form
dann soll schmecken und ich zeige euch
jetzt zuerst mal die zutaten für den
hefeteig und später dann ist es mit
unserem produkt genau übrigens zögern
unterstützt 100 fahren erste kammer in
reutlingen
nein jedes tab finden hier wird brauche
ich einen witz sei etwas warmes wasser
82 100 milliliter mir etwas von electric
einen teelöffel salz 1 1 584 kam der
laster butter ich nehme jetzt zuerst
einmal die hefe wasser und den zucker
und damit ich zum verrühren gebe ich
jetzt erst einmal einen teil des zuckers
in eine große schüssel und kann jetzt
hier hefe wasser und zucker verrühren
ihr könnt jetzt auch schon hebe nehmen
davon hier ein päckchen oder auch zwei
pickel nehmen und wir können die jede
menge dann auch etwas reduzieren wenn
ihr dafür den teig etwas länger auf
gehen
do
jetzt kommt die hefe mit dem zucker und
das ganze können jetzt entweder mit der
hand verkneten oder mit der
küchenmaschine machte immer gerne in der
küchenmaschine vielleicht beide hände
frei haben und nicht sieben minuten lang
neben muss jetzt kommen hier alle
übrigen zutaten auch mit rein natürlich
auch etwas von dem guten mann ihre
extrakte sache noch superwichtig gemüse
schmeckt wirklich gar nicht so gut und
schmeckt gut
dialekt aber egal jetzt nicht verstanden
hier das mir jetzt lasse ich schon
magneten und geht dann noch die butter
meter so der zweitgrößten wie gesagt
etwas leben bis 800 flüge werden
es ist schön das ist schön weich und
erklärt auch nicht mehr
und jetzt kann ich ihn rausnehmen doch
ganz einfach fotos stürmisch nicht vor
ihn zu einer kugel
und gebt dann ein bisschen wachstums in
einer schüssel wird hilft einfach das
führt später nicht blieb jetzt auch noch
ein bisschen was von oben drauf so
trocknet nicht aus
jetzt werde ich ihn abgesetzt etwa eine
stunde ruhen lassen und in der
zwischenzeit schon mal in manila pudding
vorbereiten
[Musik]
für den man ihn brauche ich 65 gramm
stärke 250 milliliter ml 250 30 gramm
zucker und zwei teelöffel bunny lake
packt der pudding es ist auch ziemlich
schnell gemacht ist gewillt in einem top
damit die stärke dazu da kann man
natürlich auch eine fertigpackungen
nehmen aber die braucht man gar nicht in
der packung ist nämlich auch nur stärke
drin und etwas lebensmittelfarbe und
dadurch ist nämlich auch das heute nicht
richtig schön gelb das machen wir jetzt
hier nicht hier kommt es noch die echte
vanille mit rein und oft ist auch in
fertigpackungen keine richtig echte
vanille mit dabei sondern nur angelina
roma und es ist eben nicht so ganz
lecker falls sie aber den pudding auch
etwas gelbe haben möchtet könnt ihr ein
eigelb mit der flug geben darauf wichtig
ist normalerweise hat nämlich
vanillepudding durch das typische
färbung oder nimmt in diesem leben
führen fast immer aber ich finde so
richtig schön dass für den bleibt ein
bisschen heller jetzt alle zutaten
verrühren
das heißt alles drin außerdem schwarz
der konsumismus befreien und so kann ich
die mischung jetzt während im rühren
aufkochen lassen und sich auch schon
[Musik]
foto herzog lecker sieht man dass
minister jean veil strom damit auf jeden
fall auf waffen sender pudding wird
ziemlich fix denn die starke mängel
sagte 500 milliliter aber den habe ich
es absichtlich so dicht gemacht
denn da kommt es gleich zu tun und
sobald es hier so wie hier ein geschickt
ist kann ich vom herd herunterfiel
nicht erst durch den krach noch ein
ihr könnt auch wenn jetzt sagt ich
möchte keinen quark ihn doch einfach den
quark weglassen und dann eben mit 500
millilitern milch arbeiten dort geht
auch jetzt kräftig einräumen du machst
ganzen schönen leicht wendig
diese pudding treten und schnitten sie
man beim bäcker bekommt
an dieser stelle könnt ihr gerne auch
abschmecken und wenn ihr jetzt dazu
später was ganz auf das deb-team bern
zum beispiel würde ich sagen macht hier
nochmal 40 gramm zucker mit dazu oder
einfach nach geschmack und wenn nicht
könne das ganze auch zu lassen also
etwas ganz dazu kommen wie zum beispiel
füße erst jetzt für mich die füllung und
kann sie dann mit frischhaltefolie
abdecken so bildet sich keine haut
darüber und dann muss ich immer noch auf
den hefeteig warten
[Musik]
schon aufgegangen die arbeitsrichter
wird schon im 17
und da kommt datei gibts drauf und den
werde ich jetzt zu einem roten rechteck
ausrollen einfach immer weiter ein
bisschen mehr leben so dass eben nicht
auf der arbeit nicht kleben bleibt
jetzt nehme ich jemanden lexmark masse
und die streiche jetzt noch kurz durch
und schießt damit einfach kleine
türmchen auch verschwinden und es könnte
dann direkt auf die platte machen
[Musik]
durchgestrichen und jetzt welchen hier
auf die farbe streichen
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmen wir einfach oft oder
früchte eurer wahl
ich habe die johannisbeere passen
wirklich super dass du denn der teig
dann mittels hat die klinischen betrieb
und deswegen nämlich ist dies auch im
johannes brenz und dann nehmen sie am
besten eine gabe und können so die
hornisten einfach
[Musik]
wir verteilen und jetzt kann ich die
zeit hatte ganz vorsichtig auch vor und
zwar richtig schon fest und vor allem
gleich mit
[Musik]
und jetzt können sie die rolle zurecht
schneiden in 2 bis 2 5 cm breite stücke
das sieht dann so aus und da verbindet
sich darum bitten die füllung mit dem
zeigt das heißt wenn ihr ganz genau was
sich die schöne schnecken haben möchte
dann friert ihr das ist so ein so etwa
eine stunde
und danach werden wir dann zugeschüttet
und dann geworden und zum einzelnen lege
ich die rollen jetzt in frischhaltefolie
und kannte so richtig schön zu schnellem
und dann so richtig einstimmen
[Musik]
nach etwa einer stunde ist die rolle
schon ein bisschen fester noch nicht
ganz eingefroren und offizieren und die
preise rolle und die werde ich jetzt
einfach wieder einführen zu zeigen ich
hab so auch immer wann elo schmecken auf
vorrat und kam dann immer schreiben
unter schneiden hier muss ich jetzt die
frischhaltefolie entfernen und dann das
ganze etwa zweieinhalb zentimeter breite
scheiben schneiden
ich sehe auch dass die schnecken der
richtig schöne form haben vor allem
erkennen auch den teig richtig toll und
so kommen wird in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 20 bis 25 minuten bitteschön
goldbraun sind
[Musik]
die vanille schmecken fertig und habe
jetzt mal mit diesem schnee bestreut und
ich kann von glück sagen dass wir die
fotos zwischendurch machen müssen sind
würde ich die wenn sie warm sind
wahrscheinlich immer alle schon zu
putzen
das ist einfach genial hier einmal für
ihren chor ein stück morgens lwk genau
und ich finde da durch das sich die
schnecken eben erst eingefahren habe und
dann zugeschnitten habe hat sie haben
eine richtig tolle form also das ist
echt eine ganz ganz tolle tipps und
etwas die kamera wieder aufgeht und die
wachstum wieder oh mein gott ich muss
immer geben
ich mache mich immer immer wenn die
kamera aus bagdad den spruch also was
schmeckt sehr lecker ich probiert auch
wenn ein stückchen dazu ein kaffee mit
milch und fand ihr dieses rezept nach
machen wollt geht auf meinem blog auf
verließen flotter steht noch mal alles
ganz genau und wie gesagt können die an
früchten nehmen was etwas ab was der
herr baum im garten hergibt oder das
strauch und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß dabei probiert auf jeden fall den
tipp mit dem einfrieren aus und die
übrigen schnecken die jetzt noch im
gefrierfach habe die gibt bei uns
nächste woche oder übernächste woche
oder auch erst in einem monat in einem
bisschen mehr für mich noch ein bisschen
noch mehr als die doppelte
wahlempfehlung haben wollt dann macht
einfach die doppelte menge
vanillepudding rein also bis zum
nächsten mal
lasst uns mal im schnitt klicken
aber aus
[Musik]
und
starten selbst hierzu arbeitet könnte
einmal gefallen tun will jetzt nicht
darum wirklich nur vergänglichen lustig
sein ein bisschen diese actionreiche
nicht wenn die daten ende so langweilig
und alles zugestellt
und ich habe ja noch ein päckchen aber
soll er war der hunger also pack sind
humor aber an die hat schon etwas
mitgebracht haben einkaufen muss ich
hier zu arbeiten ja eine muss er richtig
oder ich hab ja das gibt es immer nur
vom sommer bis april
[Gelächter]
[Musik]